knock knock who's there Panther Panther
who Panther no pants I'm going to Emmie
thank you thank you welcome to up all
night I'm a knight I'm a horse neigh
we've got a great show for you today
topic number one games and apples apples
don't come with very many games loaded
on them or do they try this open up
terminal applications utilities terminal
type in Emacs press Enter
hold down escape and press X and then
type in Tetris boom you can also type in
pong solitaire and uncharted 2 meow
just kidding neh but don't worry if you
ever see someone playing Emacs Tetris
and you fear they may be your high-score
simply run over to their computer and
hold down command option eject their
computer will go to sleep in a matter of
seconds and even though it's just asleep
and no data is lost for all they know
you completely bricked it the next time
you're at a page where text is masked
like the way passwords are copy and
paste code number 1 from this video's
description into your browser's URL bar
and press Enter as soon as you do that
all masked text will become unmasked and
everything put into that text field from
now on will be visible copy code number
2 from this video's description and
paste it into a text editor like notepad
then save the document as a dot VBS file
put it right on the desktop by opening
this file you will cause a never ending
dialog box to appear the secret to
stopping it is to press ctrl alt delete
and into the process W script but come
on we can do better than that copy code
number 3 from this video's description
and paste it into a text editor like
notepad save the file as a dot VBS
right-click on the file and create a
shortcut on your desktop now let's have
a little bit of fun with people who use
internet explorer rename and change the
icon so that the shortcut looks like
Internet Explorer but here's the trick
when the icon is double clicked sure
enough Internet Explorer launches but
what your victim doesn't know is that
every eight seconds his or her computer
is going to type the phrase I eat donkey
balls whether they're searching for
Bieber wallpapers or emailing their poor
sweet grandmother every eight seconds
against their will I eat donkey
balls boom right there and finally let's
in with the YouTube Easter egg some of
you may have already known this but if
you pause a YouTube video and then use
the arrow keys left and right to go back
and forth and force the video to buffer
you can break the spinning buffer balls
and play a little game of worm before we
go is the most important part of the
show here are three links to check out
even if they keep you up all night first
good old Jeff from wacky gamer gives us
an Oldham tour in the Cataclysm beta and
if you haven't seen it yet Danielle from
over at trade chat put together a
fantastic list of pop-culture references
and Wow and finally a teaser check
vsauce next week for a special cameo
from the winger
ponies are small versions of me